[Music]
good evening everybody welcome to the
annual council meeting so we're going to
say prayers and sukar pintail we'll say
our prayers thank you
Heavenly Father we meet today as a new
council with new members new challenges
new aspirations for some this will be
the start of a new experience and for
others the need to learn new ways of
working help us please to adapt to new
circumstances and to work for the
benefit of all our district grant us the
grace to listen to new ideas to capture
the fresh perspectives and energy of our
new members help and encourage those who
will take on the responsibilities of
leadership in various roles across the
council whilst we recognize the need to
direct the council in its work keep us
mindful at all times of our duty to
represent those who elect us and put
their trust in us we ask for your
guidance and blessing in the coming
months and years of this council as we
face the challenges and decisions that
will surely come our way may we be
diligent tolerant respectful and
supportive of each other always
remembering that we are here to serve we
pray in the Lord's name
[Music]
well once again welcome to the annual
council meeting the first meeting of
this new council there are some notices
to start so our first remind you of some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room the fire alarm if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones or turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this room you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may recall the film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally commend as an officer's please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you finish so
I'll now move to the agenda and agenda
item 1 is the election of chairman of
the council please can I have
nominations for the position of Chairman
do I have a proposal councillor Aarthi
I think so thank you yeah I'm pleased to
propose Katherine Grandin as chairman of
the council she's previously being vice
chairman of the council I think she'll
be perfect for the Civic and the
ceremonial roles which I think she would
enjoy just enjoyed that in the past when
it comes to chairing meetings luckily I
don't think any of us have seen
Katherine's steely side yet but her
husband is at the back and I'm sure
he'll confirm it exists sir he might
have been the only person in this room
to have been a beneficiary of that so
far but some yeah I'm confident that
Katherine would be able to give the Post
that sort of gravitas that it deserves
and I'm happy to propose her I would
thank you chairman yes as a member of
the cabinet Katherine has sure that she
is diligent and also she speaks her own
mind I'm sure that as chairman of this
council she will be impartial
independent and also I think a very
thoughtful chairman and I'm happy to
second her in this position thank you
further nominations okay I'd like to
take a vote all in favor thank you
unanimous
so I declare council it wasn't okay
sorry I'd like to declare councillor
Grandin duly elected
and being elected to the office of chair
of the council hereby declare that I
take that tapas upon myself and will
duly and faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
document and ability I undertake to be
guided by the Suffolk local code of
conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office
thank you I would like to thank the
leader deputy leader and councillors for
your nomination to select me as chairman
of Bieber district council it is an
enormous honor I will do my best to
serve our district and my fellow
councillors to the best of my ability
before we continue further I would like
to invite you to join me in thanking
Barry for his service to Bebo district
council in his role as chairman and
first citizen of the district he'll be
extremely hard act to follow
and I know you will join me in wishing
him well for the future
I would also like to thank Pauling
Taylor and the Democratic father his
team for their support
i'ma have to confess my first thought
when I was muted that it might I might
be offered this position was Oh a
wonderful excuse to purchase a new
wardrobe my second was oh dear
speeches well on the first point I have
bought a new outfit and I hope that
distracts members from noticing anything
lacking in my sweet making shopping
trips aside I would like to welcome new
and returning members to this new term
for Bieber district council
congratulations on being elected during
a time of much change both locally and
nationally in the political arena I'm
delighted to welcome some younger
councillors to our chamber I'm sure that
not only rule would be a council a
chamber of political balance but the
introduction of new young members would
be the start of ensuring a wider
Democratic if graphic of councillors - I
think the time ahead will be challenging
for us councillors and I will do my best
to help the business end here in the
chamber to move forward in a democratic
and efficient way what kind of track
Kerman will I be well that would be for
you to decide but I plan to encourage
all members to take the opportunity to
speak and debate though little brevity
we'll be in good order - in turn I will
expect courtesy respectfulness and
patience to all let us plan for a
productive and successful term one of
the aspects that I have been looking
forward to in the Chairman's role is
supporting a local charity
it was not hard for me to choose Hadley
to make sure Action Alliance the group
was started in 2014 and there are now
nearly 2000 to make sure friends most of
the local shops and businesses have been
trained to become dementia friendly and
there are regular social activities for
people living with dementia and their
carers as well as many events to raise
awareness and provide assistance I hope
you will support me in helping to raise
funds for this cause which affects so
many so Stamper your mailboxes
there'll be invitations to functions my
party frogs will be out for a good cause
now back to the business of the evening
I thank you again and look forward to a
productive constructive year in this
chamber thank you
so we'll move on now to item number 2
election of vice chairman of the council
may have nominations for Vice Chairman
yes I wish to propose councillor
Adrienne Osborne for a second term as
vice chairman of the council Adrienne
has been in this role for the past year
and has done it very well particularly
serving as a substitute for deputy for
the chairman at external functions he is
a very noble and able representative of
this council and I would like to
recommend that he continues as vice
chairman thank you do we have a seconder
Celso carpenter Thank You chair
congratulations on your appointment I'm
very happy to second counts Osborn for
Vice Chairman he's well known across
council for many years and I know that
he would do the job in his inimitable
fashion are there any further
nominations
can we vote for those in those for
counsel Osborn that's carried thank you
I declare counsel Adrienne Osborn duly
appointed I Adrian Osborn haven't been
elected to the office of vice chair of
the Council hereby declare that I take
the office upon myself and will Julie
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability I undertake to be guided by the
Suffolk local code of conduct in the
performance of my function in that
office
Thank You members can I take this
opportunity of thanking my proposer and
seconder
councillor Ward and councillor Cotterill
thank you for those kind words and I
trust as I did with our former chairman
have the ability to be with you on all
your functions within the council and
Thank You members for my election thank
you thank you
item 3 apologies for absence Thank You
chair I've received apologies for
absence from councillor Mel daisy and
councillor Owen thank you
ICI 19:1 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 19th March 2019 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy could I have a proposer
counselor Osborne could I have a
seconder counselor Horan thank you can
we take a vote for that's carried thank
you
item 6 election of leader of the council
mayor have nominations for leader of the
council do I have a proposer council I
see thank you thank you congratulations
on your election yes I have I've got a
proposal a proposal for leader and it's
John Ward as those of you that were here
before no John in the previous council
brought in a slightly different style of
leadership which is a lot more inclusive
and as the new capsule moves forward
with no overall control I think that's
more important than ever
I've spoken to John at length over the
last two or three weeks as you probably
know and we have got to a situation
where I think we have an agreement to
work together to a mutual arrangement
that's to the benefit of the people of
the district in our communities and for
the good of this council moving forward
and I have every confidence that John
will be able to deliver for all of our
benefits Thank You councillor Aarthi do
I have a seconder thank you
Sabir thank thank you madam chairman
congratulations and yes I would like to
second John Ward for this position we do
need to have some continuity and I'm
pleased to hear that the leader of the
independence and him have been talking
well and that you've already started
work of there's an understanding going
on and hopefully that will continue and
I have great pleasure in second in the
proposal thank you are there any further
nominations so I don't have a nomination
that I would like to say make some
comments is that's okay
yes you may thank you
thank you it was just to say that our
green group won't be supporting our
council awards nomination as leader
nothing personal against councillor Ward
but we don't support the deal that has
been done regarding cabinet seats and
supporting the reason we we don't
support that is because simple maths
really we have four green members out of
32 councilors that's one in eight there
are eight members on the cabinet by my
maths it would seem right and
appropriate that we have agreed remember
on that cabinet I had talked suggested
we if we want to include the Lib bent or
a smaller group in the green group on
the cabinet there's no reason why we
couldn't move to a nine member cabinet
that was not seen propia for whatever
reason I I think it's worth noting that
the population of Baber voted 23% of
people who voted voted green and they
voted for a reason
that's nearly one-in-four because they
wanted to see some green policies and I
think a lot of our residents were be
shocked that our greens are being
excluded from the cabinet and just one
further thing to say I mean it's been
put to me that well it's only for a year
the arrangement and you know we can all
change after a year well maybe but maybe
not
you know people have a tendency once
they're in a job to to stay in there and
there is no mechanism built into this
deal to rotate a leadership which I
think will be a fair and sensible
arrangement of buildings arrangement a
way to rotate the leader every year
thank you thank you for your comments
I'd like to move on now and we'd like to
take a vote
now for the election of leader of the
council could you please vote for our
proposed leader councillor Ward that's
curry thank you Thank You councillor
discounsel congratulations
now on to item number seven people paper
BC 19-2 announcement from the chairman
and leader I refer you to paper BC 19 to
simply to be noted on to the am strong
leader model it's up to the leader of
the council to appoint his own deputy
thank you so moving on I invite the
leader to make his announcement thank
you madam chairman I was just being
taken I wish to thank you all for your
support and electing me lead up the
favor District Council again it is an
enormous privilege and as I have found
out over the past year and a half hard
work but it is an interesting and
rewarding role we can make a real
difference through our communities here
we provide many of the services that our
residents need and use every day and
they rely on us to ensure that we keep
delivering these whatever difficulties
we face I made a number of promises when
I was elected leader at the beginning of
last year and I can honestly say that I
believe it I have kept them came up
seized was to be as inclusive as
possible and to this end I brought
councillor Davis into the cabinet and
proposed council McCraw as chair of the
overview scrutiny committee I am mindful
that the Conservatives are no longer in
a majority but we are the largest group
and can and should play a part in the
administration of the council over the
past year and a half I have demonstrated
that I have the willingness and ability
to reach out across the chamber and I am
looking forward to working with all
groups in one way or another for the
benefit of Baber
as we start on you term the cabinet will
reflect the fact that a mutual
arrangement has been agreed to enable us
to work together it will draw on the
best talent and experience in this
chamber to enable us to address the
tasks
of us I think that this will be good for
the council as we will need broad
support for some of our more pressing
challenges particularly getting our new
joint local plan completed without
further delay and also ensuring that we
have a balanced budget for 2022 2021 and
a plan to close the gap in the years
after that I am in a position to
announce the cabinet now and so I'll be
making the following appointments I will
retain the finance portfolio and capsule
john osborne will retain the housing
portfolio council a halt will be the
cabinet member for economic growth
castle and mal vici will be the cabinet
member for the environment councillor
Aarthi will be the cabinet member for
planning and also the deputy leader
councillor Davis will be the cabinet
member for Communities councillor Parker
will be the cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
this is the former organization or
delivery portfolio the new name agreed
with mid suffer really reflects what
this portfolio is all about councillor
Busby will be the cabinet member for
assets and investments the
communications portfolio that I created
last year has a change its purpose a
number of new communications initiatives
were created thanks to Castle Grandin
these are now regular features and
working well it is still a work in
progress and further improvements will
be made but this function will be firmly
within the leaders role going forward
clearly the administration's program
cannot be aligned with the conservative
manifesto but there are many promises in
that document that would have widespread
agreement and support I'm sure the
cabinet will over the next few weeks
work out its own programme drawing from
proposals from all of its members at the
beginning of last year I listed a number
of specific projects that I wish to see
completed or in progress many of these
have been achieved but there are still
some that have suffered disappointing
delays those that are well underway in
delivering conclude our council house
cleaning program the redevelopment of
quartz Lane with the planning
application that has been approved the
improvements to the king fish and Hadley
later centers and our regeneration plans
to Sudbury following the completion of
the vision for prosperity
this is a timely announcement given the
fact that the government has also
recently announced the future high surge
fund and that that will be the basis of
a vision with the basis for our funding
bid for funding and also the Hamilton
Road prospectus has generated
significant interest the sport and
Enterprise Zone which is now seeing a
lot of activity with the development of
the site for the first major occupant
and finally our customer service this
has improved greatly with three
face-to-face access points and a new
online customer care portal and we now
have an excellent performance monitoring
system in place that reports on all
aspects of the council's business but
there are those where we do need to
apply more focus and urgency there are
still some conditions to be discharged
before working commenced at the hms
ganges site drainage being the main one
work on the Spiner it is expected to
start in early spring next year
following that first phase of 30
dwellings hopefully will commence I did
say at the start of last year that I
hoped we would have projects underway
from Bellevue Park and Sudbury for both
the land and the house a lot of progress
has been made in securing a much needed
hotel but this is clearly a very
controversial and emotive issue we will
need to think carefully about this but I
do want to see further no further delay
and lastly we do have three major
industrial sites that need long-term
secure futures the former BX plastics
factory cat await Philips event in
Glenwood and Delphian Sudbury people
must do its utmost to work with other
agencies to get the outcomes we desire
for these I've only listed a few things
but we have a lot to do and it will I'm
sure be a busy and exciting time I know
that officially Baber is now classified
as no overall control however this
should really be we are all in control
together the will is clearly there to
make this arrangement work so let's do
it thank you madam chairman
moving on to designation of committees
and Joint Committee to appoint the
following committees and joint
committees Weber overview and scrutiny
committee planning committee both the
licensing and regulatory committee joint
audit and standards committee joint
appointments committee could I have a
proposer to appoint all the committee's
listed on the agenda
Oh
councillor Busby thank you could I have
a seconder can't Sabir thank you can we
vote all those in favor
thank you thank you carry item 9 ec 19
three political balance and composition
of committees I refer you to paper BC 19
3 and appendices aim be in the tabled
pack I would like to invite Ken Robinson
the deputy monitoring officer to
introduce paper BC 19 3 thank you Thank
You chair and the purpose of this report
is to comply with the provisions of the
local government and Housing Act 1989
which require a local authority to
review the allocation of seats to
political group set every annual meeting
of the council or as soon as practical
after that meeting report also 60
council approval of the composition of
the committees which also must be freed
at the annual meeting thank you thank
you can I have a proposer cancer ward
thank you and could I have a seconder
please
councillor Busby thank you
can we take a vote in favor the paper
thank you
that's Kerry thank you okay item 10
election of chairs and vice chairs of
committees so we're going to elect chair
and vice-chair for the following
committees and joint committees babe
overview scrutiny committee planning
committee Weber Licensing and regulatory
committee joint audit and standards
committee joint appointments committee
may have nominations for the chair of
overview and scrutiny committee please
council Aarthi thank you I'm hang of
this now yes I'd like to propose Alister
Alistair has previously been vice
chairman and chairman of the committee
he was vice chairman when Barry Gatsby
was chairman and during that period I
have to say they renewed my faith in the
scrutiny function I think they did an
excellent job
Alistair went on to chair it himself and
everybody does things differently but my
view is that Alistair has transformed
the way that we deal with scrutiny and
I'm confident in the fact that he will
be able to chair this committee and move
things forward properly exercised to
scrutiny function I'm looking forward to
a slightly more themed approach to
scrutinizing issues and I commend to you
Alistair thank you could I have a
seconder to council McCraw please
councillor Ward thank you just just echo
what Karthi said
you take a vote for oh sorry
are there any other nominations thank
you
so like all those in favor that's
carried Thank You mayor have nominations
for the vice chair of our V over V and
scrutiny committee else award yes I'd
like to nominate councillor Aires to
continue in the role of vice chair of
this committee she's proved an able
deputy to council McCraw and she will
provide that consistency and continuity
going forward thank you thank you now
have a seconder
Thank You council McCraw echoing what's
already been said I'd like to nominate
or second the nomination of councillor
as his vice chair we've worked together
before I look forward to doing so again
are there any other nominations please
no other nominations may we take a vote
please for council Aires carried thank
you may have nominations for the chair
of planning committee councillor Ward
yes I'd like to nominate Council of beer
to continue in the role of chair of
planning committee
I know that he's been in this position
for a long time but I believe at this
stage while we're waiting for a new
joint herbal plant to be approved and
implemented we need a wise owl in the
chair of this committee to see us
through what could be an uncertain few
months as we may face challenges from
developers who may wish to test our
existing planning policy and it and
somebody of the caliber of Castle beer
who knows the function of this committee
who knows planning inside out it would
be prudent for us to retain him for that
purpose thank you and could I have a
seconder for councillor beers
appointment
thank you cancer halt combinations thank
you maybe take a vote to please for
councillor beer
thanks against and those against please
right courage thank you oh that's a beer
oh can I say a few words usually it's
customary
after ones been elected Justine thank
those people that failed to form and my
colleagues behind me and certainly the
one across the floor and also noted the
one who voted against me but I would
just like to say to those members
officer that I did actually listened
this mornin to councillor sue carpenters
words and I'll certainly take them on
board at least try to thank you now
mayor have nominations for the vice
chair of planning committee please Oh
counselor RC thank you that last one got
you worried didn't it Peter
okay I have pleasure in proposing
Stephen plum for the position of vice
chairman I will be absolutely honest to
say that I would rather be proposing him
as chairman of the committee but I do
accept that a year as vice chairman will
be good experience for him and so Peters
credit he'll be an excellent chairman to
be vice chairman tooth I'm sure so I'm
looking forward to Stephen gaining the
experience and I'm happy to propose him
for the vice chairmanship thank you and
don't have a seconder for councilor plum
please councillor Davis thank you any
other nominations right can we take a
vote please
councillor plum all those in favor thank
you carrot may have nominations for the
chair of Licensing and regulatory
committee please that's the hold
yes I'd like to propose mark you and
seconder please cut Sabir thank you
thank you I'm sorry thank you any other
nominations
thank you no other nominations can we
take a vote on this please
those in favor thank you
any against thank you carried mayor have
nominations for the vice chair of
Licensing and regulatory committee oh
sorry
I just like to thank you all very much
and I look forward to the challenge may
have nominations for the vice chair of
Licensing and regulatory committee
please can't siharan yes I'd like to
nominate Sue Carbondale please she's
very experienced fair level-headed and
everyone's favorite counselor so she'll
do the role extremely well I feel um
very happy to propose her could I have a
seconder for C Carpentier please do I
just say one little thing and that is
that Sue and I were both elected at the
same time 28 years ago and I hope she
won't mind me saying that
she was obviously a much younger lady at
the time and she now has
tasks I think to be able to deal with
this sort of role thank you thank you
are there any other nominations
thank you can we take a vote for think
often Taylor's vice chair that's curry
Thank You mayor have nominations for the
chair of going toward it and standards
committee please councilor sue cough and
Dale thank you madam chairman I've used
my gravitas to propose councillor harem
for this role he is an experienced
counselor and he already has a
significant track record working on
standards issues so I'm very happy to
propose him this year thank you could I
have a seconder please I can't sir Chris
well thank you I'll second that
yeah any other nominations
thank you no other nominations
can we vote for counselor Torrens please
that's carried thank you mayor have
nominations for the vice-chair of joint
audit and standards come just to clarify
we don't need a vice chair for the joint
order and standards committee because we
actually share chairmen so if one can't
make it the other one would Smith
sabich's chairman Thank You mayor for
nominations for the chair of joint
appointments committee please o-katsu
Osborn thank you madam chairman my and
Matt add my congratulations to those of
others tonight
it gives me pleasure to nominate John
Ward
could I have a seconder please counselor
Aarthi thank you that can only make
sense because the committee is made up
the leaders of the three largest groups
in each County and as leader of this
council it would obviously make sense
for John to chair that on their behalf
are there any other nominations
no maybe fate for councillor Ward please
carried thank you may have nominations
for the vice chair of joint appointments
committee we don't need that thank you
so moving on to item 11 BC 19 for
appointments to outside bodies for
2019-20 I refer you to pay for BC 19 for
and Appendix A in the table pack I would
like to invite the leader to introduce
paper BC 19 4 and moves the
recommendation in the report thank you
we have to point quite a number of
representatives on various outside
bodies as a result of the election there
have been significant changes to the
makeup of this council and so there been
it has been necessary to replace quite a
few people and also expecting further
changes you have Appendix A the current
thinking and proposals for for names of
these bodies there are still one or two
gaps and I am still working with the
leaders of the other groups to fill
those gaps but we have essentially the
vast majority of the names in place and
so consequently I
recommendation of 2.1 that the name
counselors be appointed to the outside
bodies as detailed in this appendix and
that we can follow up with the remaining
few vacancies as when we've got the
relevant names in place thank you none
has taken me place on Western Suffolk
Community Safety Partnership which was a
to be confirmed appointment at the end
so can I have a seconder for this
proposal please yes please do HF the
green Green Wave's countryside project
its traditional for the two counselors
that represent pine wood take the two
places on this as I'm no longer on if I
think of Zack and Rick should take the
two places I'm quite happy to hand over
my Spade thank you that seems fine thank
you
could I have a seconder now please and
this is any other further comments just
scampering through this and I've noticed
the Ipswich strategic planning area
board has Lee Parker without substitute
and I can confirm I think that I can be
his substitute on that if that meets
with everybody's approval that's being
noted thank you
I'd add again I've been asked for its -
a few substitutions here I understand
that the joint waste management board
which has little this mail visa as its
member I understand that I might be
required to substitute on that which
kind of fits in the Southwest
partnership role that's being noted
thank you
any other comments yes I think actually
um earlier on this afternoon we were
talking about the flood sorry bear with
me where I'd find it Suffolk flood risk
management committee we were talking
about having councillor Davis as the
representative and councillor gold as a
substitute is that acceptable no I think
sorry to confuse the issue I think we've
got council McCraw as councillor
daughter if that's acceptable to you
later of course yes of course that's
been a tit thank you
any other comment so names to be added
otherwise if not can we have a seconder
please council Horan thank you
everyone content can we move to the boat
then please all those in favor
thank you that's carry right item 12
appointment of counselors to the shared
revenue and partnership committee in
accordance with the joint Arrangements
established with mid Suffolk District
Council and its which Borough Council
Council is asked to appoint to cabinet
members and to substitutes to serve on
the committee for the current municipal
year the political balance rules do not
apply to Beiber's appointees mayor have
nominations please council ward
yes I wish to nominate the Council of
John Osborn and a councillor Derrick
Davis as the representatives on the
shared revenue partnership with
councillor sue Aires
and Kelly Parker as a substitute thank
you could I have a proposer then please
second death sorry the seconder please
council Aarthi thank you all those in
favor
thank you carried appointments to the
Suffolk joint Standards Board in
accordance with the joint Arrangements
established with mid Suffolk District
Council and Suffolk County Council
Council is asked to appoint three
councillors to serve on the board for
the current municipal Year the political
balance rules do not apply to bathers
appointees who cannot be the chairman of
the Council for members of the cabinet
the nominations have been tabled could I
have a proposer
Celso carp and Dale thank you and a
seconder councillor Ward thank you all
those in favor
carried thank you
appointments to the joint Kip C and
travelers steering group Council is
asked to appoint for councillors to the
joint Kip C and traveler steering group
I believe some nominations have been
tabled are there any further nominations
could I have a cancer Lindsay I'd like
to nominate to councillor please do you
have a seconder Kathleen see ya John
would council would thank you any more
nominations right so we'll take them as
a group thank you could I have a yeah
all those in favor thank you thank you
that's carried appoint appointments to
Council working groups I refer you to
the proposed appointments in the tabled
pack are there any more appointments
right could I have a proposer please
councillor John Osborn and a seconder
councillor coffin Dale thank you all
those in favor
thank you that's carried
right I think we have come to the end of
our business for the evening come I
declare this meeting councillor Davis I
believe if you have something you'd like
to say yeah Thank You chair for your
indulgence and I just like to
congratulate both the leader John Ward
and the deputy leader Clive Aarthi on
making this this happen it's not been
easy and I know the amount of work they
put in over the last couple of weeks to
try and get everything sorted I
understand that we dissenters totally
understand that but I believe that this
is the best interest of favour this
mutual arrangement may not last then
there may be some disagreements for sure
there will be but it's got us off to a
fantastic start we've hit the ground
running we've got continuty know I'd
like to congratulate both councillor
Ward and Counting laughing here thank
you for your comments so I now declare
this meeting closed at 6:21 p.m. thank
you for this evening